hi my name is shannon oda and i'm an
assistant professor at seattle
children's in the university of
washington
and today i will be talking about
overcoming cell therapy barriers in the
suppressive tumor microenvironment with
engineered proteins
here are my disclosures
so it's an exciting time to be in the
cancer immunotherapy field
there's an increasing appreciation that
the immune system can be harnessed to
control and eradicate cancer
and that has been shown now in several
publications and also in the nobel prize
it was awarded in 2018 to jim allison
into sucrohonjo for a checkpoint
blockade
one of the major cell types that is
focused on
for cancer immunotherapy approaches is t
cells and so t cells are used in
cancer immunotherapy because they are
specific
so as the guided missiles of the immune
system t cells are able to target and
destroy harmful cells in the body
while ignoring normal healthy cells t
cells
are also long lasting so after killing
tumor cells
t cells can remain in the body as a
memory population
poised to respond if cancer returns and
also t cells are very powerful
and that a single t cell can kill a
hundred thousand cancer cells
however not all patients have sufficient
tumor-specific
endogenous t cells to re-engage with
therapy
so for those patients we've developed an
approach where we restore the
anti-cancer immune response with t-cell
adopted immunotherapy
which we like to call a living drug so
in this approach we take t cells from
the patient or healthy donor
we genetically engineer those t cells to
recognize the tumor
by inserting a gene that is a cancer
targeting receptor such as a car
or a tcr and we then infuse those t
cells to a patient to find and destroy
cancer
however there are many challenges for t
cells in the tumor microenvironment
that can impede or prevent the t cell
from
destroying the tumor cell some of these
obstacles include metabolic competition
such as reduced nutrients or oxygen and
so t cells aren't able to access those
nutrients as the tumor cell
usurps all of those available metabolic
reagents
also t cells may have issues migrating
to the site of the tumor
and tumors can upregulate inhibitory
ligands
which bind to the inhibitory receptors
on the t cells causing the t cells to be
shut down
so thinking back to our adoptive cell
therapy approach
we have the opportunity to further
engineer our t-cells
at the stage where we're engineering
them to recognize the tumor so we can
help our t-cells overcome some of these
inhibitory
barriers and be better equipped to find
and destroy cancer
so the questions are how can we best
engineer our t cells to improve
anti-tumor function
in the context of a suppressive tumor
micro environment
but also what approach improves function
with minimal manipulation
so what is the the best approach that we
can do
to afford the most uh benefit for these
t
cells so as i mentioned t
tumor cells can express proteins on the
surface of the cell that shut down the t
cell so in this cartoon we see the tumor
cell has upregulated an inhibitory
protein
shown in the light blue that binds to an
inhibitory receptor on the t cell which
is shown here in the dark blue
and binding of this inhibitory protein
to the inhibitory receptor on the t cell
results in the t cell being shut down
and with the t cell shut down tumor
cells can continue to survive and divide
so how can we engineer our t cells to
overcome this inhibition
so an approach that we've worked on that
has worked out really well has been to
essentially replace a break with an
accelerator
where we are rewiring inhibitory or
death receptor signaling
so we take the um inhibitory receptor
ectodomain
here in the blue and we swap out the
signaling components for that of a
co-stimulatory receptor
shown here in orange which normally
gives a boost to the t cells
so with that we've generated a new
fusion that has the inhibitory receptor
ectodomain
combined with the co-stimulatory
intracellular signaling domain
making a new fusion protein we've termed
an immunomodulatory fusion protein
or an ifp for short so now when the ifp
binds to the inhibitory protein
on the tumor cell instead of an
inhibitory signal
t cells now get a stimulatory boost from
the ifp and they're able to once again
kill the tumor cell
some of the advantages of adding
co-stimulation with ifps are that we're
abrogating an inhibitory signal
and replacing it with co-stimulation in
a cell intrinsic manner
when we pick uh inhibitory ligands that
are on two more targets we're lowering
the threshold of activation to these
tumor targets specifically
and also several studies now with car t
cells have shown that
the selection of different
co-stimulatory domains can influence the
phenotype
so depending on the co-stimulatory
domain we pick we can bias our t cells
towards more of an effector memory or a
central memory phenotype
and also influence the metabolism of t
cells
so one of those barriers of the tumor
microenvironment that inhibits
t cells responding to tumor cells is
vast ligand
vaseligand is normally expressed on t
cells as a mechanism to kill cancer
cells but also to induce apoptosis and
overstimulated t cells
however tumor and other tumor
microenvironment cells can also
upregulate fast ligand
to induce apoptosis of tumor
infiltrating t cells
so the fast fast ligand axis has been
shown to be a limiting factor for t cell
therapy
so there are several studies now showing
that vaseline signaling to t cells can
reduce their efficacy and essentially
protect the tumor from
t cell therapy
but fast ligand is overexpressed in the
majority of cancer tumor
microenvironments
so shown here in this chart in the left
panel most of the tumors that were
analyzed in this particular study
have over expressed vast lagoon
expression relative to
normal healthy tissues
so the way that we've decided to
overcome the fastest
luggage issue is to essentially cheat
death where we are replacing fast
signaling with foreign db
fast and foreign both signal as trimmers
so by pairing the fast active domain
with the 4mbp signaling domain repairing
two trimers
and we are essentially replacing a death
with a pro-survival co-stimulatory
signaling domain
best legion positives positive cells in
the tumor microenvironment induce
lymphocyte death
but t cells can also upregulate fast lag
and after stimulation
so there's a potential here to generate
a positive signal for t
cells in an auto costingutory manner
so the first experiments that we did we
engineered t cells to express
fast-forward db and then we tested them
in a proliferation assay
so in this assay we load our t cells
with a dye called ctv
and so if we leave those t cells
unstimulated they're very bright for the
for the dye shown on the left panel but
as they're stimulated with the low level
tumor cells so in this case
fbl which is a mouse leukemia cell line
we see that our tcr only t cells in the
black
remain undivided they're not
proliferating
but the tcr plus fast forward vbt cells
are proliferating and diluting out the
dye and shifting to the left side of
that panel
so we were able to get um proliferation
um
where otherwise these t cells wouldn't
be activated to a very low level of
stimulation so stimulating
a hundred thousand t cells with six
thousand tumor cells
we also wanted to evaluate the ability
of these t cells to
uh kill cancer cells so we use the inky
site instrument
which allows us to monitor t cells
killing tumor cells over time
with microscopy time-lapse images and so
the incusi instrument sits within a cell
incubator
and we're able to monitor how t-cells
kill tumor cells over multiple days
so to determine if ifps could improve
eradication
of leukemia in culture i developed an
assay to really push our t
cells where we have our t cells in
culture and then we add in red-labeled
leukemia cells to those t cells
but then again as i wanted to push these
t cells i add additional batches of
tumor cells every 24 hours
so these t cells have to kill wave after
wave of tumor cells
and we've dubbed this the serial killing
over time assay or the sco
assay
so this is these are some images from
that assay um in the left panel as
as a picture taken from the beginning of
the assay where there are several red
tumor cells interspersed with under
uncolored t cells but by the end of the
first 24 hours
most of those red tumor cells have been
eradicated by the t cells
so when we compared our control t cells
in the black
with our t cells that had been
engineered with the fast-forward bbip in
the red
with the first edition of tumor cells we
saw that both populations of t cells
were able to potently kill off the tumor
cells
however when we added tumor cells the
second and third time
we saw that the t cells that were the
control t cells that did not express the
ifp
were starting to lose control of the
tumor cells and there was increasing
tumor signal
as shown on the y axis and the
increasing
additions of tumor cells however when we
engineered our t cells to express the
fast form the ifp
we found that they were still able to
potentially kill off those tumor cells
and if anything they seem to be getting
better at their job as by the end of the
70 hour period
there are a few tumor cells left in the
dish
we next wanted to examine if the
fastball and bbt cells exhibited reduced
fast-mediated death
so by expressing the fast-forward bb
receptor on these t-cells are we
providing a decoy mechanism
to prevent fast lag into binding the
endogenous fast receptor
so to examine endogenous fast signaling
we looked at caspase-8 which is part of
the fast death pathway
following antigen stimulation death
signals are induced via the past
fast pathway so when we looked at active
cast phase eight
and our control t cells shown here in
the black we see that there's up
regulated caspase-8
indicating fast pathway activation this
is compared to
fast deficient t cells shown in the gray
but when we looked at our fast form bbt
cells we see reduce active caspase eight
similar to those in the fast efficient t
cells suggesting that we
are providing a decoy mechanism and
these t cells are experiencing
what reduced fast pathway signaling
so we found that fast form bb improved
the function of the t
cells in vitro but how are we altering
t cell programming
as i mentioned at the beginning of this
talk we know that there are several
metabolic barriers to anti-tumor
immunity
so there's limited nutrients in the
environment as they're being
used by the tumor cells and also t cells
have been shown to have
reduced number of mitochondria as they
are
exposed to the inhibitory to a
microenvironment
several studies have shown that
increased foreign bb singing can
overcome some of these obstacles and
improve metabolism
so form bb stimulated t cells exhibit
higher spare respiratory capacity
which is the reserve energy store for
cells
and this has been linked to long-term
persistence of memory cells
so in these two papers on the left shown
with form bb
card t cells and on the right shown with
1 db agonism via an antibody
we see that there's increased spare
respiratory capacity for the t cells
that have increased volume db signaling
we saw similar results with our fast
form dbt cells
and that they exhibit higher spare
respiratory capacity which was similar
to those publications i just showed you
and also when we looked by microscopy at
the number of mitochondria
we saw increased mitochondrial
biogenesis in the t cells that expressed
fast form bb
relative to our control t cells so they
are generating increasing
numbers of mitochondria and they have
increased metabolism
um pre similar to previous reports so we
are getting a good foam db signal
through this ifp resulting in
uh remodeling of the metabolism of these
t cells
so we're very excited about these
results we next wanted to test them in
our
in vivo mouse models so we first tested
the fast form bb ifp
and our mouse model of leukemia so for
this model we inject
four million tumor cells into the mice
on day zero
by day five the tumor has disseminated
as is shown here in this ivis image
where the
tumor has spread out in the peritoneal
cavity of these mice
so then we give them a million t cells
after treating with cytokine
which is a chemotherapeutic drug which
we also use in our human patients
and then we assessed for survival over
100 day period
so for this study we did not give them
nice il2 injections which is a
supportive cytokine for the t cells so
once again we're pushing the t cells to
do their job in the absence of support
from il2
and we also gave a single t cell
transfer
when we checked for persistence in the
blood we found that our fast form bbt
cells were highly represented
more highly represented in the blood
than our control t cells
supporting that they had enhanced
persistence
and when we looked at the survival curve
we found that our tcr
t cells that did not have the ifp as
shown here in the solid black line
did prolong survival but ultimately did
not rescue the majority of mice
so while we were getting a survival
increase relative to mice that received
chemotherapy only
as shown in the hatched um black line
the dotted black line
we still did not rescue the majority of
mice
however when we uh treated with
fast-forward uvt cells as shown here in
the red we did
see a significant increase in survival
so
by adding in this extra engineering of
adding in this
ifp we were able to get significant
increase in survival
for mice that received these
ifp-positive t-cells
so we were very excited about those
results the next hurdle that we wanted
to overcome was to look if these ifps
could improve t-cell immunotherapy of
solid tumors and the solid tumor that we
focused on is pancreatic
cancer and pancreatic cancer is a cancer
that
desperately needs improved therapies so
in this chart
there are several cancers shown and in
the purple arrows you see the
changes in survival over a 40 year
period
and for several of these cancers there's
been remarkable
increases in survival with new therapies
and new research
as the treatment options are improved
over time
however pancreatic cancer is done at the
very bottom
and there's very little improvement in
the outcomes for
patients with pancreatic cancer some of
the challenges of pancreatic cancer are
that early detection is uncommon
pancreatic cancer tends to spread
quickly and recurrence is likely
so to model pancreatic cancer in mice we
use the kpc genetically engineered mass
model
of pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma or
pda
and we use this model as it
recapitulates
the majority of human patient cancers
in that it has mutations in k-ras and
p-53
and this is held under held under the
control of a pancreas-specific cree
so these mice spontaneously and
continuously generate tumors from the
epithelial cells in the pancreas
so with these mutations they're
constantly generating tumors so we'll
never be able to cure these mice
but we would hopefully be able to shift
the curve with an effective therapy
this model has been successfully used to
screen drugs to predict therapeutic
efficacy in patients
so the results that they saw in this
mouse model translated to humans
so another reason that we like to use
this model
and also the kpc model recapitulates
several barriers to t
cell function of human pda including a
suppressive microenvironment
so in previous work mesothelion
is a target antigen that has been shown
to be reliably expressed
in various stages of pda both in human
disease and in the kpc mouse model
however um when t cells
tcrs were generated to mesothelion and
those tcrt cells were used in therapy
we found that the tumor-specific t cells
became rapidly dysfunctional in the
tumor microenvironment
so these data are from day eight post
transfer and if we compare t
cells pulled from the tumor versus t
cells from the spleen
we already see a marked decrease in the
ability of these t cells to produce
effector cytokines
so the way that this model works is that
we
screen these mice by ultrasound to
determine when tumors arise
so in a healthy mouse we see on the left
side we see a nice
normal healthy bright pancreas but on
the right side we can now visualize
tumors by ultrasound
and so these mice would be enrolled to
study and randomly assigned to treatment
groups
so for our initial studies in solid
tumors we enrolled mice to
the study when tumor was detected we and
then
gave them an enrollment dose of 10 to
the seventh each of tcrt cells
and also mesothelioma pulsed splenocytes
as an in-vivo antigen boost for these t
cells
again after cytosine which is that
chemotherapeutic drug
and then we took the mice down at day 28
and analyzed
to see how our t cells were doing and
again this is in the absence of il2
therapy
so when we looked in the tumor by
histology we saw an increased
intra-temporal concentration of
ifp-positive t-cells at day 28
so we saw increased number of t-cells
were able to
infiltrate the tumor
and looking at it in a little bit of a
different way when we did a paired
injection
where we combined controlled t cells
with our
fast formed bt cells at a one-to-one
ratio and injected those into the mice
by day 28 there was a significant
skewing of the fast-forward bbt cells
in the tumor so although they started at
a 50-50 mix
by day 28 it was more of an 80 of the t
cells in the tumor where our vascular
bbt cells relative to about 20 percent
of the tcronic t cells
so we next um started the survival study
so again we enroll those mice to study
when tumor is detected by ultrasound
and then we give them an enrollment dose
of 10 to the 7th t cells and
mesothelioma
spanish size post cytosine and then we
repeat the t
cell apc infusion without cytosine every
two weeks for a total of three infusions
and then assess the mice for survival
so as we've shown previously
immunotherapy with mesothelion targeted
t
cells improved survival from pda
relative to mice that received
chemotherapy only as shown in the dashed
line
the solid black line showed the tcr
controlled t-cell
therapy but what was really exciting for
us was to see the shift of the curve
that we achieved when we
treated with my t-cells engineered to
express the fast-forward bbt
cells so now we see a shift of the curve
of a median survival of 37 days for the
control t
cells to 65 days for our fast foreign
cells
and this was strongly statistically
significant
we bled the mice for t cell persistence
28 days after their final t cell
transfer
and we were unable to detect transfer t
cells and the ones surviving
tcr only control mouse however for all
four of the surviving
fast-forward uv t-cell recipients we
were able to detect transfer t
cells so we saw increased t-cell
persistence
in the mouse and also increased
trafficking as we showed um
by histology and bipolar cytometry we've
also now
taken these studies into the iv8 ovarian
cancer model
and we found similar results where we
get enhanced survival
of mice that receive our fast-forwarding
t cells in the ovarian cancer model
and we've also translated these
experiments with human
uh t cells with human primary t cells
and we've
uh again used the incucite assay with
pancle and tumor cells
and so um in the gray without any t
cells we see that the tumor
cells go out over time um when you add
in
either tcr only t cells or control t
cells with just the mesothelion specific
tcr
or in the blue um a construct that just
has the
the fast active domain so it's a decoy
receptor we see there is
reduced um tumor persistence but really
the big difference is with
the a red curve where you see that the
fast-forward bt cells are able to
eradicate the tumor cells in the dish
so we're very excited about these
results not only for the in
increased survival benefits that we've
seen
but also in that as
we know there are several obstacles that
inhibit the anti-tumor t cell response
that i presented at the very beginning
we now know that ifps have the potential
to overcome
several of these inhibitory barriers so
with our ifp
t cells we've seen enhanced metabolism
as well as reduced or ablated
suppression by decoy
so we've seen reduced endogenous fast
signaling
due to our fast formula expression we've
seen reduced exhaustion of our t cells
they're able to kill round after round
of tumor cells as we've shown in the sco
assay
there's a lower threshold of activation
these t-cells are able to proliferate
with a very low level of stimulation
um and also these t-cells are able to
get into the tumor
and persist in in vivo so we have
increased intra temporal concentration
as well as
persistence in our mouse models
so with that i'd like to thank my lab we
just started on may 1st
and so edison chew is the first member
of my lab i'd also like to thank my
former mentor phil greenberg
and the group of researchers that worked
with me during my time there
including nicola garcia cody jenkins and
katrina polizzikov
and also our collaborators dan riddell
mike jensen and ode chapui
and our sources of funding which include
the leukemia and lymphoma society
juno therapeutics and then we have
several new
projects that we're working on now and
we're always interested in new
collaborations and partnerships
so please feel free to reach out if you
have some ideas you would like to work
with us
thank you for your time